la semaine dernière eric k boulianne se
rend sur le site de l' agence du revenu
du canada pour faire une demande de
prestations d'urgence du canada la pcu
mais surprise quelques a déjà encaissé
deux chèques de 2000 $ à son nom sur mon
profil et j'ai vu que toutes les infos
bancaires avaient été changés donc c'est
ça qui au départ sonner la cloche
lui-même clients chez desjardins sa
prestation d'urgence a plutôt été
envoyés à la banque de montréal avec mes
informations de permis de conduire y
avait mes informations de mon numéro
d'assurance sociale fait qu'ils ont pu
sourire le contre le centre antifraude
du canada dénombre une cinquantaine de
signalement de vol d'identité liées à la
prestation canadienne d'urgence depuis
la mi avril
et lorsque le stratagème me répéter les
sommes peuvent atteindre des dizaines de
milliers de dollars
la fraude en général et sous rapporté
donc ce convoi est normalement est
quasiment toujours seulement la pointe
de l'iceberg
le cofondateur de flir systems une
entreprise montréalaise qui est des
institutions financières à prévenir les
vols de données n'est pas surpris que le
programme de prestations d'urgence du
canada soit la cible des fraudeurs
évidemment qu'on parle de tout projet
gouvernemental continuum entre la
sécurité et la rapidité ici gouvernement
vraiment fait le pari de la rapidité et
je pense qu'avec les conditions dans
lesquelles on essaie le faire on savait
qu'il y avait une possibilité que
certaines personnes essayent de des
fraudes et de fraude et le système est
donc nous avons mis en place des mesures
pas pour filtrer avant parce que ça
aurait ralenti de bien des mois la
livraison de cet argent urgent et
essentiel mais on a mis en place des
mesures pour déceler est arrivé à
reprendre cet argent au fur et à mesure
que à la pandémie continue les victimes
de fraude sont invités à les signaler au
centre antifraude du canada aux services
de police locaux et à leurs institutions
financières ici c'est mon coup dessus
radio canada montréal